well now to the war in ukraine kiev says
that its troops have liberated more than
20 settlements in the past 24 hours as
they continue
a rapid advance in the eastern harkeef
and donetsk regions
now the map here that you're looking at
it shows the front line 12 days ago and
then
yesterday and you can see the latest
territory that ukraine says it has
recaptured from russian control that is
in light blue russia is dubbing its
withdrawal from the region it's calling
it a regrouping
overnight ukrainian officials have said
that russian airstrikes on civilian
infrastructure had caused widespread
power outages ukrainian president
zielinski says that russia is
deliberately trying to deprive people of
electricity and heat and today the mayor
of harhif described these strikes as
russian reprisals for ukraine's recent
territorial games
this abandoned tank is one of many left
behind in the panic russian retreat from
the khakiv region
in a nearby village vehicles and piles
of ammunition testified to the russians
hasty withdrawal in the face of the
ukrainian advance ukraine's military
command has pledged to push on
the liberation of settlements from the
russian invaders and the vendors region
continues
as briefly reported during the retreat
russian troops quickly abandoned their
positions and fled deep into temporarily
occupied territories or the russian
federation
this trend persists
the russian command has played down the
setback
and president vladimir putin has yet to
acknowledge it instead striking a
defined note on western sanctions
russia is confidently handling the
external pressure
essentially a financial and
technological aggression coming from
certain countries
the economic blitzkrieg tactics they
were counting on haven't worked which is
obvious to everybody including them
putin's silence has not stopped growing
criticism of the military's dismal
performance
that could turn out to be a problem for
the president despite a harsh crackdown
on descent since the outbreak of the war
putin can still count on the russian
orthodox church to be a pillar of
support
as we live in a very difficult time our
prayer is a special one for the head of
our state and supreme commander-in-chief
vladimir vladimirovich putin who bears a
special responsibility
but should the war continue to go badly
for russia pressure will mount on a
leader who not long ago seemed
unassailable
all right for more now we want to bring
in justin crump he's an intelligence and
security expert and the ceo of the
intelligence consultancy
joins me tonight from washington dc in
the united states mr trump it's good to
see you again
it seems every time we talk the
situation for the ukrainian military
improves and that is the situation
definitely tonight at least that's what
it appears to be um what does what we're
seeing what does this tell us about the
state of the ukrainian armed forces in
your opinion
that we've taught before as you said i
mean
combat power
comes from three different areas the the
physical so what you actually have
people tanks guns
the moral the purpose of which you're
fighting and the conceptual so what you
do with it all
and i think what's really clear here is
that ukraine's made great progress in
all those areas we knew the moral
component was high we knew that their
physical component was growing with what
they've been given
from the west and what they were able to
generate from their people and it's that
conceptual component that's really come
into play here with this amazing
operation distracting the russians
hiding the gathering of forces inside
hakeem and then pushing forward so
successfully so fast that we've seen at
this stage so i mean the president
zielinski he knew what he was doing all
along it seems he's now for weeks if not
months he's been um telegraphing to the
world that there's going to be a
counter-offensive in the south
actually that was meant for the east but
he he said that knowing that it would
draw russian forces to the south is is
that what he's done
yeah very much so and
i mean i would stress though i do think
the counteroffensive and hudson is also
real i don't want to diminish that it is
not just a fate or a play there is real
momentum there and there is a real
opportunity there um i think what they
did so cleverly was committing forces to
that and having a lot more available
than perhaps people had expected and
being able to assemble them in secret
and deploy them in the east
you and i talked before about the
importance and difficulty of perception
on this battlefield at a time when uavs
are prevalent satellites
social media as well
it's very very hard to assemble troops
like this for that level of security so
an extraordinary effort by the
ukrainians to gather five brigades worth
of troops equivalent to a nato division
with such secrecy and as you said they
played a blind and really yeah and you
know we are seeing reports of and it's
astounding ukrainian troops outnumbering
russian forces
um in this section of the front line by
as many as eight
to one now
can you tell us how
how can this happen considering the fact
that when we're looking at the cities of
what is it beyonce and izim which have
been used as staging posts for the
russian invasion how can they let their
troop numbers be decimated like
this i'll be fair that the claims of
eight to one have come from the russian
side and i'm pretty sure when you're on
the receiving end of a assault like this
that's making the most of what we call
maneuver warfare so very mobile warfare
where you overwhelm your enemy in time
and space by just hitting them so hard
i'm not sure they knew precisely how
many people they were facing i'm
absolutely certain it felt like eight to
one but this is all about
creating superiority in a small area um
to overwhelm the enemy so it's actually
ukraine's concentration of force
secretly that was so important here that
meant they could punch hard with an
armored force originally lots of mobile
forces behind that to break through the
russian front lines which were a bit of
a shell in this area it's where they
sent forces to recover that were damaged
earlier in the war and they've never
really rebuilt and then of course once
they got through that shell there was
just nothing behind it and hence the
russians have collapsed so fast and so
far um that it's been overwhelmed in
that way so it's all about concentration
of force locally but that's been so hard
to achieve on this battlefield until now
and you use the word collapse i've heard
other military analysts using that word
today as well i mean that's a that's a
serious word to be using when you're
talking about this situation
particularly for the russian military i
mean are are we seeing a cataclysmic
event unfolding right now for
russia
um
yes but within certain boundaries i
think it's a collapse of this part of
their military forces on this front
it won't necessarily persist
you know i don't think we should think
just because ukraine's advances far and
fast that it can be maintained now
ceaselessly ukrainian forces have to
regroup russia's had some time to try
and build new defensive lines
so it's not inevitable this route will
continue um it might though and i think
the most important thing here is the
change of tone by russian commentators
actually the open blaming of putin for
the first time really for these failures
and him being held slightly more to an
account now it's early days in this but
that's the big change that we haven't
seen so far during this conflict i think
all eyes are on what russia does next
and how far and far this rock spreads
but at the moment they should hold other
parts of the south they can possibly
stabilize back but they are definitely
now on the back foot in a defensive
position which is not what they expected
the failure of the kiev offensive you
know we we saw a purge of russian
military and intelligence staff at least
that's what was reported
considering what we're seeing right now
what is that going to mean i mean are we
talking about something of similar
magnitude that if so
what's that going to mean for the
military and what does that explain why
we're not hearing much from
moscow
yeah partly i think um part of the
russians just don't know how to react to
this it's caught them completely off
guard they've shown throughout the
conflict they just don't have a speed of
reaction to change circumstances uh
that's to do with their structure it's
to do with their mentality it's partly
to do with that early losses that
actually have left them on the back foot
really throughout this conflict in many
ways even when they were advancing they
were they were struggling um and of
course repeated purges do not make for a
better leadership team uh otherwise
everyone would do it all the time i mean
it's already a sign of failure but you
can only purge so many times before
there's no one left um and again they're
running out of people to blame which is
why the president who previously has
been almost floating above criticism in
many ways in the eyes of the russians is
now personally being mentioned as
actually he's responsible for this um
that is a real change i don't think they
know how to react so again all eyes on
whether they try and escalate this
that'll be very very hard for them at
this stage there is that warning of of
course if russia tries to escalate it
could indeed collapse
um which could be something
quickly at this point again it may
stabilize they may hold what they have
and try and dig into the winter but
regardless in a lot of very painful
decisions being made in moscow right now
and i think having to face real failure
in the face right now for the first time
i think you have to be honest about that
justin crump as always mr crump
excellent analysis we appreciate your
time thank you
thank you
all right i want to pull in now justin
bronk he is a senior researcher in the
military team at the royal united
services institute in london it's good
to have you with us tonight
what do you see when when you hear about
these these and we're reporting them as
these continued advances that we're
seeing in the eastern and southern parts
of ukraine how do you read that i mean
are we talking about real progress for
ukraine
i think we're talking about more than
progress this is uh at this point a
fairly staggering uh turning point in
the war
this is certainly the most serious uh
reverse that russia has suffered since
it was forced to retreat from its
multi-pronged assault on kiev back in
april uh they've
lost and the ukrainians have liberated
more than 3 000 square kilometers of
their own territory in about five days
it's one of the most successful military
offensives uh in modern history uh and
indeed it's also at so far
come at a relatively light cost for
ukraine particularly in the northeast uh
down in kersen the longer running and
much more
anticipated counter-offensive uh it has
been much more bloody for for both sides
uh it's a much more attritional struggle
but in the north essentially ukraine
having
managed to find a gap and make a punch a
hole in the russian front lines uh in
the harkief region at a place called
baliklia
were able to rapidly push reinforcements
in and drive mechanized forces deep into
the russian
lines of communication and because the
russian military is so overstretched in
ukraine they're so short of infantry
they already were relatively short of
infantry compared to the size of their
army at the beginning and they've lost
more than 48 000 dead and nearly 100 000
plus casualties in total so they're
really struggling having only started
mobilization efforts in july that's not
enough time to train new people and so
once ukrainian forces broke through at
balaclear and got into the rear areas
there were really no reserve forces that
the russians could use to stop the
advance and it's led to this cascading
collapse of one entire flank of the
russian position in ukraine what's more
worrying for the russians is that the
pressure is still on incarceration down
in the south and so they can't move
their forces that are concentrated down
there to try and reinforce the north
they're trying to throw in barely
trained reserves from russia to stop the
the retreat but so far it seems that
they're they're having difficulties this
is a very dangerous position for the
russians at the moment mr burton you
know you use the word collapse i mean
are we looking at the russian army in
the process of collapsing now i mean
they still of course outgun
um the ukrainians but
it sounds like this is a an
inter-military collapse that you're
describing
it certainly appears that way uh and we
we knew that the russian military had
serious morale problems not least
because the the shortage of troops means
that their troops don't get any time off
the line so we're seven months into the
invasion many of those troops have been
in combat or at least in the war zone
the entire time mostly in the open with
very poor equipment and food and now
they're faced with
essentially a war of movement for which
they're just not prepared in the north
and so many troops have simply abandoned
their heavy equipment and their vehicles
and once you do that of course you can't
stop because you don't have the
equipment to defend yourself so for
example in izumi we see these enormous
stockpiles of ammunition of tanks other
armored vehicles because an entire
russian flank just basically left their
equipment and tried to get out of
an encirclement they were suddenly
threatened with
and once that sort of thing starts it's
really very difficult to stop um without
a huge body of troops coming in to kind
of provide a counter punch and step
steady the line and that's exactly what
the russians don't have here ukraine
probably doesn't have the logistics
capacity to both secure fully everything
it's already liberated
and also keep pushing without risking
overstretch so they may be forced to
slow down but at the moment the russians
seem to be falling back almost faster
than the ukrainians can pursue them in
the northeast and in case and they're
still grinding forward and of course if
the morale panic spreads to kersen and
we saw a collapse there as well
suddenly at that point the regime in
moscow even starts to look very shaky
and worried yeah it is a remarkable turn
of events a fast turn of events as well
justin bronk we appreciate your analysis
tonight thank you
all right from the battlefield analysis
to the political input i want to pull in
now mr marcus faber he is a member of
the german parliament with the german
liberal party the fdp he also sits on
the defense committee in parliament mr
farmer it's good to have you with us
tonight um we're we're hearing there you
just heard it from this um military
analyst these are remarkable turns of
events in favor of
the ukrainian military
knowing that is now the time to increase
those weapons shipments to ukraine i
mean that's being discussed here in
germany are you in favor of that do we
does germany need to send more weapons
to keith
the germany athlete absolutely has to
send more weapons to create the liberal
party is very much in favor for it
basically since the beginning of the war
i think that would always have
been better if the uh germany would have
decided for having weaponry two months
ago so the um
the current offensive the ukrainians are
um posing could be supported even better
but um we haven't had this decision two
months ago we need absolutely needed now
so far
no country has sent in western battle
takes um to ukraine
do you think germany should now lead the
way with this and change that
germany already has sent thanks to
ukraine departing and i think we have to
do more about it we can do more about it
when we're talking about books when
we're talking about mata this is
where we have a lot of ins and supply um
i think these are the first steps that
have to be taken now
and what about you i know there are
members of the german parliament and
also in the german government to
oppose sending
more weapons or heavy weaponry
what argument do they have now
considering that we're talking about
possible russian retreats taking place
this is a good question everybody asks
themselves um i think some colleagues in
the bundestag um still fear a kind of
escalating conflict in ukraine but i've
been in ukraine i've been in kiev i've
been in hackathon command house and
sloverians it's a full-scale invasion
it's a full-out war it's a brutal war
it's a terrorist war and there will no
be conventional invasion so germany
should do what we can do and it includes
sending tanks as well
marcom salva a member of the defense
committee
with the german bundestag mr farber we
appreciate your time and your insights
tonight thank you
thank you